SPEAKER_00: Good morning, Jessica. Ready to talk real estate?
SPEAKER_01: I think so? It's pretty overwhelming honestly. Um...
SPEAKER_00: I get that. Toronto's market is... intense. So you mentioned you're looking at both living in the property and potentially treating it as an investment. Tell me more about that.
SPEAKER_01: Well, I'm twenty-nine, making about a hundred and ten thousand. I've been renting downtown for five years.
SPEAKER_00: What are you paying in rent currently?
SPEAKER_01: Twenty-eight hundred for a one-bedroom near King and Spadina.
SPEAKER_00: Ouch. So that's... what... thirty-three, thirty-four thousand a year just in rent. No equity building. What kind of down payment have you saved up?
SPEAKER_01: About ninety thousand. Been saving aggressively for three years.
SPEAKER_00: That's impressive. So with ninety thousand, you're looking at properties around... let me think... four-fifty if you put down twenty percent to avoid CMHC insurance.
SPEAKER_01: But is that realistic in Toronto these days?
SPEAKER_00: For a decent one-bedroom condo downtown? Probably not. I'm seeing listings in the six to eight hundred range for anything decent. Um, what areas are you considering?
SPEAKER_01: I was looking at King Street West, maybe Liberty Village, or... or further out like North York.
SPEAKER_00: Big price differences there. King West you're talking seven-fifty plus for a one-bedroom. North York might be more like five-fifty to six-fifty.
SPEAKER_01: So I'd need to put down less than twenty percent?
SPEAKER_00: Likely, yeah. With ninety thousand, you could do about fifteen percent down on a six hundred thousand place. But then you're paying CMHC insurance - that's... um... about twenty-four thousand on a six hundred K mortgage.
SPEAKER_01: Twenty-four thousand just for insurance?
SPEAKER_00: It gets rolled into your mortgage, so you pay interest on it too. But it does allow you to buy with less down. The alternative is waiting until you have that full twenty percent.
SPEAKER_01: How long would that take at my savings rate?
SPEAKER_00: If prices keep rising... well, that's the catch-twenty-two. By the time you save more, prices might be even higher. What's your monthly savings capacity right now?
SPEAKER_01: About fifteen hundred a month. Sometimes more if I get bonuses.
SPEAKER_00: So eighteen thousand a year. To get to twenty percent on a six hundred thousand place, you'd need another thirty thousand. That's almost two more years, assuming prices don't rise.
SPEAKER_01: And they probably will rise, right?
SPEAKER_00: Hard to predict, but Toronto's had pretty consistent long-term appreciation. Immigration, population growth, limited supply... though interest rates have cooled things down lately.
SPEAKER_01: What are mortgage rates looking like now?
SPEAKER_00: For a five-year fixed, you're looking at around... um... six and a quarter, six and a half percent. Variable rates are a bit lower but riskier.
SPEAKER_01: That seems high compared to a few years ago.
SPEAKER_00: It is. We had that crazy period around two percent during COVID. But historically, six percent isn't unreasonable. My parents bought their first place at twelve percent back in the eighties. Can you imagine?
SPEAKER_01: Yikes. So what would my monthly payments look like?
SPEAKER_00: On a five hundred thousand mortgage at six and a half percent... let me calculate... probably around three thousand a month. Plus condo fees, property taxes, insurance...
SPEAKER_01: Condo fees in Toronto are brutal, aren't they?
SPEAKER_00: They can be. I'm seeing anywhere from four hundred to eight hundred monthly, depending on amenities and building age. Older buildings sometimes have special assessments too.
SPEAKER_01: Special assessments?
SPEAKER_00: When the building needs major repairs - roof, elevators, whatever - and the reserve fund isn't enough. Each unit gets hit with their share. Could be ten, twenty thousand or more. I've seen some really nasty surprises.
SPEAKER_01: That's terrifying. How do you plan for that?
SPEAKER_00: You can request to see the building's reserve fund study, but honestly it's hard to predict. Newer buildings are generally lower risk, but you pay more upfront.
SPEAKER_01: What about property taxes?
SPEAKER_00: In Toronto, about one and a quarter percent of assessed value annually. So on a six hundred thousand place, maybe seventy-five hundred a year. That's... uh... about six hundred a month.
SPEAKER_01: So all-in I'm looking at close to four thousand monthly? That's more than my rent.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, but you're building equity instead of just paying your landlord's mortgage. Plus, you can write off some expenses if you're using it as an investment property.
SPEAKER_01: How does that work exactly?
SPEAKER_00: If you rent out a room or use part of it for business, you can deduct a percentage of your costs - mortgage interest, property taxes, condo fees, even depreciation.
SPEAKER_01: But then I'd have rental income to pay tax on?
SPEAKER_00: True, but often your expenses offset most of the rental income in the early years. The interest portion of your mortgage payment is fully deductible.
SPEAKER_01: What if I bought something specifically to rent out?
SPEAKER_00: That's a different game entirely. You'd need at least twenty percent down, can't use CMHC insurance. But all your costs become deductible against rental income.
SPEAKER_01: Would that make more financial sense?
SPEAKER_00: Depends. You're still paying rent somewhere, so you have two housing costs. The rental property needs to cash flow positive or close to it. What kind of rental yields are typical in Toronto? Actually, let me think about that...
SPEAKER_01: I have no idea. Three percent? Four?
SPEAKER_00: More like two to three percent gross. So a six hundred thousand condo might rent for... what... three thousand a month? That's thirty-six thousand annually, so six percent gross yield.
SPEAKER_01: But my costs would be more than that.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Mortgage payments alone would be thirty-six thousand annually. Plus property taxes, condo fees, insurance, maintenance... you'd be cash flow negative for years.
SPEAKER_01: So it only works with appreciation?
SPEAKER_00: Pretty much. You're betting that the property appreciates faster than your annual losses. Toronto's done well historically, but... no guarantees, right?
SPEAKER_01: What kind of appreciation rates?
SPEAKER_00: Over the long term, maybe four to six percent annually. Though we had that crazy run from twenty-fifteen to twenty-twenty where prices doubled in some areas.
SPEAKER_01: And recently?
SPEAKER_00: Prices have pulled back maybe ten to fifteen percent from the peaks. Interest rates really cooled demand. But they seem to be stabilizing now.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe a good time to buy?
SPEAKER_00: Could be. Though trying to time real estate markets is... it's tricky. If you're buying to live in long-term, timing matters less than finding the right property.
SPEAKER_01: What about different property types? Condos versus houses?
SPEAKER_00: Houses give you more control - no condo fees, no board decisions. But in Toronto, even townhouses start around eight hundred thousand. Detached homes, forget about it.
SPEAKER_01: What do houses typically rent for?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on size and location. A three-bedroom house might rent for four to six thousand monthly. Better cash flow potential, but much higher entry cost.
SPEAKER_01: And I definitely don't have that kind of down payment.
SPEAKER_00: Not yet. Though house prices have come down more than condos. I've seen some listings drop fifty to a hundred thousand from their peaks.
SPEAKER_01: Still way out of my range though.
SPEAKER_00: For now. But real estate's a long game. You could start with a condo, build equity, then trade up to a house in five to ten years.
SPEAKER_01: Is that a typical strategy?
SPEAKER_00: Very common. Use your first property as a stepping stone. Some people keep the condo as a rental when they upgrade, if they can qualify for two mortgages.
SPEAKER_01: How hard is it to qualify for multiple mortgages?
SPEAKER_00: The lenders look at your total debt service ratios. Generally want your housing costs under thirty-two percent of gross income, total debt under forty percent.
SPEAKER_01: And they count rental income?
SPEAKER_00: Usually only fifty to seventy-five percent of it, to account for vacancies and expenses. So it helps, but not dollar-for-dollar.
SPEAKER_01: What about closing costs on the purchase?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. Land transfer tax in Toronto is brutal - you pay both provincial and municipal. On a six hundred thousand place, that's about... let me calculate... seventeen thousand just in land transfer tax.
SPEAKER_01: Seventeen thousand? Just in tax?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, Toronto has the highest land transfer taxes in Canada. Plus legal fees, home inspection, title insurance... budget another five to eight thousand for miscellaneous costs.
SPEAKER_01: So twenty-five thousand in closing costs?
SPEAKER_00: About that. Though first-time buyers get a rebate on the provincial land transfer tax - up to four thousand. Are you a first-time buyer?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, never owned before.
SPEAKER_00: Good, that helps a bit. There's also the Home Buyers' Plan - you can borrow up to thirty-five thousand from your RRSP for a down payment.
SPEAKER_01: But I'd have to pay that back?
SPEAKER_00: Over fifteen years, yes. About twenty-three hundred annually. But it's interest-free, and you're borrowing from yourself.
SPEAKER_01: I only have about twenty thousand in my RRSP though.
SPEAKER_00: So you could use that. Combined with your ninety thousand in savings, you'd have a hundred and ten for down payment and closing costs.
SPEAKER_01: That would work for something around six hundred thousand.
SPEAKER_00: Right. Fifteen percent down, plus closing costs. You'd need about a five hundred thousand mortgage. Are you pre-approved yet?
SPEAKER_01: No, should I be?
SPEAKER_00: Definitely. It shows sellers you're serious, and you'll know exactly what you can afford. Mortgage brokers can often get better rates than going directly to banks. Though I should mention, I'm, uh, not certain about current broker rates...
SPEAKER_01: Any other costs I'm missing?
SPEAKER_00: Property insurance - maybe hundred and fifty a month. Utilities if they're not included. And you'll want an emergency fund for unexpected repairs.
SPEAKER_01: How much emergency fund?
SPEAKER_00: For a condo, maybe ten thousand? Houses need more because you're responsible for everything - roof, furnace, plumbing.
SPEAKER_01: This is starting to feel really expensive. Like, really expensive.
SPEAKER_00: It is a big financial commitment. But remember, you're already paying twenty-eight hundred in rent. Some of that mortgage payment is building equity.
SPEAKER_01: How much equity in the first few years?
SPEAKER_00: Not much honestly. Most of your payment goes to interest initially. On a five hundred thousand mortgage, maybe eight to ten thousand goes to principal in the first year.
SPEAKER_01: Plus appreciation hopefully.
SPEAKER_00: Right. If the property appreciates four percent annually, that's twenty-four thousand on a six hundred thousand place. Much more meaningful than the principal paydown.
SPEAKER_01: But appreciation isn't guaranteed.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely not. Real estate can be cyclical. We might see flat prices for years, or even declines. That's why location and long-term thinking matter.
SPEAKER_01: What makes a good location?
SPEAKER_00: Transit access is huge in Toronto. Subway lines, GO trains. Walkability, good schools if you plan to have kids, proximity to employment centers.
SPEAKER_01: So downtown is still better than suburbs?
SPEAKER_00: For long-term appreciation, probably. But you pay a premium for it. Sometimes suburban properties offer better cash flow if you're renting out.
SPEAKER_01: What about new construction versus resale?
SPEAKER_00: New construction means no immediate repairs, modern layouts, energy efficiency. But you pay a premium, and there's construction risk - delays, builder issues.
SPEAKER_01: Construction risk?
SPEAKER_00: Projects can get delayed years. Builders sometimes go bankrupt. Plus you don't know what the building culture will be like until people actually move in.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe stick with existing buildings?
SPEAKER_00: For your first purchase, probably safer. You can see exactly what you're getting, check the building's financial statements, talk to current residents.
SPEAKER_01: How do I evaluate a building's finances?
SPEAKER_00: Look at the reserve fund balance, recent special assessments, planned major repairs. A good building should have strong reserves and proactive maintenance.
SPEAKER_01: This is a lot to think about.
SPEAKER_00: It is. Real estate's probably the biggest financial decision most people make. Take your time, do your research, don't let emotions drive the decision.
SPEAKER_01: Should I start looking seriously now?
SPEAKER_00: Get that pre-approval first. Then you can shop with confidence. Market's been pretty stable lately, so there's no huge rush, but good properties still move quickly.
SPEAKER_01: Any final advice?
SPEAKER_00: Buy the worst unit in the best building you can afford, rather than the best unit in a marginal building. And remember, you can always renovate or upgrade later.
SPEAKER_01: That's helpful. Thanks for walking through all this.
SPEAKER_00: My pleasure. Real estate in Toronto is complex, but it's still been one of the best long-term wealth builders for most people. Just go in with your eyes open.
SPEAKER_01: I definitely feel more informed now.
SPEAKER_00: Good luck with the search. And call me when you find something you're serious about.